>> ♪ ♪
>> DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT
CANDIDATE AND SOCIALIST BERNIE
SANDERS SAID CHINA DID MORE TO
ADDRESS EXTREME POVERTY THAN ANY
COUNTRY IN HISTORY.
LISTEN.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO SAY ABOUT
CHINA, IN FAIRNESS TO CHINA ANDs
LEADERSHIP, IF I AM NOT
MISTAKEN, THEY HAVE MADE MORE
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING EXTREME
POVERTY THAN ANY COUNTRY IN THE
HISTORY OF CIVILIZATION.
THEY HAVE DONE A LOT OF THINGS
FOR THEIR PEOPLE.
>> HE IS RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE WORLD BANK THE
NUMBER OF POUR IN CHINA WENT
DOWN TO LESS THAN 10 MILLION.
I WONDER HOW THEY DID THAT.
THE CHINESE SOCIALISTS KILLED
MILLIONS OF POOR PEOPLE.
DEAD PEOPLE ARE NOT POOR; JUST
DEAD.
THAT WAS THE GREAT LEAP FORWARD.
AFTER THEY USED A TOOL THAT
BERNIE SANDERS DESPISES,
CAPITALISM.
I WISH WAS THERE A VISUAL
METAPHOR FOR BERNIE SANDERS'S
ARGUMENT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I HAVE TO KEEP WATCHING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT WAS ONLY AFTER CHINA
ADOPTED FREE MARKET PRINCIPLES,
THAT THEY TRANSFORMED THEIR
ECONOMY.
>> A HOUSE HORRORS MORE HUMANE.
THOSE WHO SCREAM ABOUT
INEQUALITY AND CREATE EVEN MORE
INEQUALITY.
YOU END UP WITH 2 CLASSES.
THE POOR AND THE POWERFUL.
IT HAPPENED IN CHINA AND SEEMS
TO BE HAPPENING IN SAN
FRANCISCO, L.A. AND BALTIMORE
TOO.
CHINA WENT COMMUNIST RESULTING
IN MASS MURDER AND FORCED
ABORTION OF FEMALE BABIES AND
FAMINE.
THE NUMBER OF DEAD IN CHINA HAVE
TO BE COUNTED IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS.
YES, PRAISE IS ORDER FOR CHINA
FOR ABANDONING BAD IDEAS.
MAYBE BERNIE SANDERS SHOULD DO
THE SAME.
>> YOU ARE EXCITED ABOUT THIS
TOPIC.
IT BOTHERED YOU.
>> IT DID AND I LISTEN TO YOUR
MONOLOGUE.
AND I LOOK DO YOU KNOW WHAT I
WROTE DOWN.
I MIGHT HAVE BEEN SITTING NEXT
TO YOU FOR MANY YEARS.
I DON'T HAVE MUCH TO ADD.
BERNIE SANDERS SAID CHINA HAS
DONE A LOT FOR HIS PEOPLE.
NO IT'S TO HIS PEOPLE.
AND THIS QUASI-CAPITALISM.
THEY CREATED A HUGE
MIDDLE-CLASS.
WE SHOULD WANT TO SELL THEM A
LOT OF THINGS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
MONEY TO BUY.
WHAT IS UPSETING TO THEM THERE
IS NO RULE OF LAW AND THEY DON'T
HAVE PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO TAKE
THEIRICAL TAP AND MOVE IT
SOMEWHERE ELSE?
WHERE DO THEY WANT TO PUT IT?
IN THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE
IT'S SAFE AND YOU HAVE RULE OF
LAW.
I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY IN
THE UNITED STATES STAND UP FOR
THE HUMAN RIGHTS PROBLEMS.
BERNIE SANDERS DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT THAT AT ALL IN THE
INTERVIEW.
I DON'T SEE HOW THE DEMOCRATS
ARE DIFFERENTIATING THEMSELVES
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP AS ALL ON
CHINA.
THE PRESIDENT, HOWEVER, HAS
STARTED, IN THE STATE OF THE
UNION, HE SAID THE UNITED STATES
WILL NEVER BE A SOCIALIST
COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DOING ANYTHING
TO STOP THAT.
>> THEY ARE JUST MOVING
LEFTWARD, JUAN.
THAT'S NOT A QUESTION, I ADMIT
IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I AM GLAD YOU ADMIT IT.
OTHERWISE IT WOULD BE VERY
CHINESE OF YOU.
I THINK BERNIE SANDERS IS
SPEAKING AGAINST THE HEAVY
HANDED USE OF TARIFFS WHICH IS
DRIVING THE WHOLE ECONOMY TO THE
VERGE OF RECESSION AND DAMAGING
THE CHINESE ECONOMY.
HE IS SAYING THERE IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CLOSER TIES
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND CHINA.
WE DON'T HAVE TO DEMONIZE THEM
AS EVIL AND TERRIBLE.
IF IT'S NOT THE FEDERAL RESERVE,
THE CHINESE PRESIDENT IS OUR
ENEMY.
HE IS TRYING TO GET OUT OF THAT
MIND SET.
YOU ARE RIGHT TALKING ABOUT
CHINA MAKING PROGRESS.
MAYBE YOU ARE GIVING TOO MUCH
CREDIT TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
AFTER THE TORTURE AND THE
MURDER, THEN YOU SEE THE CHINESE
PEOPLE START TO RISE UP WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EMPLOY FREE
MARKET IDEAS LIKE PROPERTY AND
INVESTMENTS AND BRINGING IN
AMERICAN COMPANIES.
IT'S STILL THE CASE.
YOU CAN SEE IT FROM THE NEWS WE
HAVE TODAY ABOUT HONG KONG AND
THE PROTESTS.
YOU CAN SEE IT IN TERMS OF NO
FREE PRESS.
YOU CAN SEE IT AND UNDERSTAND IT
IN TERMS OF REPRESSION AND HOW
THEY TREAT THE MUSLIM MINORITY
IN CHINA.
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT IS STILL
HEAVY HANDED.
I GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR 3/4 OF
REDUCTION FOR GLOBAL POVERTY HAS
BEEN IN CHINA.
BERNIE SANDERS IS SPEAKING LESS
ABOUT THAT, THAN WHY CAN'T WE
WORK WITH CHINA INSTEAD OF USING
TARIFFS THAT IS NOT TO OUR
ADVANTAGE?
IT'S HURTING OUR ECONOMY AND
GERMANY AND CHINA'S ECONOMY.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SEE BERNIE
SANDERS GET ON AN AIRPLANE AND
MAKE THAT SPEECH IN HONG KONG.
THEY CONTINUE TO PRAISE THESE
COMMUNIST COUNTRIES.
IF HE WAS NOT PRAISING CHINA, HE
WAS PRAISING VENEZUELA OR
PRAISING RUSSIA.
HE IS A LEADER OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AND NOT EVEN IN IT.
HE IS A DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
WHAT HE HAS TO UNDERSTAND IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT HE IS
DOING AND DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
IS SHOWING THE POSITIVE THINGS
OF CAPITALISM.
IT CAN BE BETTER, BUT IT LIFTED
MORE PEOPLE UP OUT OF POVERTY
AND PROVIDED MORE WEALTH IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD THAN
ANYTHING ELSE.
YET HE CAN'T BRING HIMSELF TO
ACTUALLY GIVE CAPITALISM THE
CREDIT IT DESERVES.
>> EMILY, YOU HATE CAPITALISM?
>> BERNIE SANDERS IS SUCH A
FARCE.
HE COMES ON AND SAYS MAKE A
STRONG STATEMENT FOR DEMOCRACY
AND HUMAN RIGHTS AND THIS IS
NOT.
WE HEARD NOTHING ABOUT THE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
WOULD BERNIE SANDERS RECOGNIZE
TAIWAN AS A COUNTRY?
THIS IS SO MUCH HE FAILED TO
ADDRESS THAT CHINA REPRESENTS.
HE SHOT DOWN THE THREAT QUESTION
AS WELL.
WHY AREN'T WE HEARING HIS
POSITION ON CHINA'S STATED
PURPOSE OF NUCLEAR AND TRADE
POWER ON THE ARCTIC CIRCLE
COUNCIL.
IN 2017 THEIR PRESIDENT SAID
CHINA WILL BE A GLOBAL POWER AND
THEY WANT TO IMPROVE THEIR
COMPAT CAPABILITY.
HE SAID WE WILL NEVER SWALLOW
THIS BITTER FRUIT OF DOWN
GRADING OUR INTERESTS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SOMEONE ELSE'S
BENEFIT.
FOR BERNIE SANDERS TO SAY THEY
ARE NOT A THREAT TO US OR WON'T
PUT THEMSELVES FIRST AND IGNORE